congratulations okay this is so exciting
how has it been how's home life been
with an entire new baby
chaotic definitely chaotic sleeplessness
uh amazing chaotic but beautiful and
just overall a an amazing experience oh
Heather how are you enjoying being a mom
in this way for the first time because I
know you're a mom but in this way what
is that like for you I'm obsessed I
didn't think I'd be this obsessed with
him and
love him so much you know and literally
not want to leave his side so she's
everything that you would expect like
she's seriously a rock star I mean she's
doing every single mom thing you could
possibly do and even even if she doesn't
have to do them she wants to do them so
she'll wake up at three in the morning
to feed she'll change all the diapers so
she'll do all the mom things because she
likes doing them so they've just been
bonding so well
um and I couldn't be happier actually uh
what are your diaper changing skills
like are we good me or how are we doing
all right
mine are fantastic I just asked for my
wife for help
um how is Tristan doing because I know
you opened up recently about some health
issues but apparently he's okay now
um what can you share about that yeah so
we caught it early on he had tongue tie
lip tie and she
common babies but
um tongue tie is not always uh caught
early on so we were able to catch it
early on I uh we hired a lactation
specialist who then ended up being a
tongue tie specialist caught the tongue
tie so in the beginning it was rough
because he wasn't latching he wasn't
eating
um we were having a lot of difficulty it
was very challenging and really
upsetting and
um it was basically like he was drinking
a milkshake through a straw with a hole
so he was burning too many calories he
wasn't able to eat and so we had to get
a laser done which released the tongue
tie and lip tie and we do like little
exercises on his mouth every day to keep
it um untied and now we're looking
really good yeah good what would you say
tomorrow oh good good what would you say
is the best part about having Tristan at
home like just a new baby
um for me it's skin on skin excuse me
skin on skin and breastfeeding I it was
important to me to breastfeed and you
know there's always challenges that come
along with breastfeeding and
um we worked through them but that
that's my favorite part was Tristan at
home oh what about you Tariq I mean we
have a baby in the house again right
it's just it's an incredible experience
you know together we brought life into
this world and you know he's he's around
all the time and he's sleeping and
eating and pooping and it's just an
incredible experience and we're really
enjoying every moment of it I love that
okay so married new baby now business
partners do you think the show made you
stronger as a couple
absolutely yeah we had so much fun
filming this show you know and I have
been flipping houses for a really long
time and to bring Heather in and get a
different perspective on the business
has been extremely beneficial I mean the
designs we knocked them out of the park
well she did we did some really fun and
exciting projects so I'm really excited
to share with everyone and I learned a
lot from him you know he's an expert
flipper he's been doing this for so many
years and he's the I think I think the
best in the world I mean you are my
husband do you think he's the best in
the world so I got the best teacher and
flipping houses is hard but so much fun
and yeah I have to say like I I love it
I love it I brought my real estate
expertise into flipping and um I think
I'm a decent designer huh you're gonna
find out on this Thursday
it's got to be such a relief for you
Heather to do a show like this a reality
show but also real estate base and there
not be drama
it's a different type of drama right and
it is a breath of fresh air because I
get to film with my husband and we get
to spend more time together and uh we're
also executive producers on the show so
that was really nice to have some
creative and have some control because
yeah I have zero control
not in my mouth right yeah TARC for you
what surprised you most about Heather on
the show
what surprised me the most
um how fast you pick things up to be
honest I mean I feel like you know we
flip 10 houses together and that's
that's a huge accomplishment for someone
that's never flipped a house and
although I've done it for a long time I
mean there are a lot of moving Parts
there's you know timelines and change
orders and estimates and you know
property valuation and I feel like you
know within halfway through our very
first flip like she fully understood the
business and she really just took all 10
to the finish line so I mean we just we
worked really well together yeah uh what
would you say was the biggest challenge
becoming business partners you have to
pick one
that's me saying
no no no that wasn't very often because
he has this thing where he really has a
hard time saying no to me
um but you know at first I wanted to
spend more money because it's you know I
do like spending money I have high-end
taste right so I do high-end real estate
and I think I learned very quickly on
this is our business and we're here to
make money we're not here to lose money
we're not here to
um oh his hat
so I learned very early on like this is
important that we oh baby love
that's my note yeah Tark how excited are
Taylor and Braden about having a new
brother have they helped out at all
I mean they're yeah they're they're so
excited you know they love holding them
they love playing with them and
throughout the entire pregnancy they
were both excited you know uh never at
one time was I nervous about bringing
Tristan into the world with the existing
family you know because from day one
when they found out they were having a a
sibling they were so excited they want
to learn about the the baby process they
followed Heather in the app the size of
the baby the changes in the baby so they
were along this journey with us and um
you know the smiles on their faces when
they saw their little brother was
priceless so cute yeah
and held him and they're like I want to
hold him I want to hold in my turn you
know I'm longer it was
just look at me Whispering I'm trying to
like not be loud because of the baby
okay oh my God does this experience make
you want to have more kids
we just talked about this last night
yeah
um you never know right you never know
what what's gonna happen but I do think
that Tristan's gonna be our only one
together
um because we already have Taylor and
Braden we have our marriage we have
careers and I think being such an
obsessed mom I it's hard to want to go
back to work it's hard to want to go
back to filming it's hard to want to
yeah you know do other things besides
just being with him so I think I'm
tapped out yeah
well your baby's beautiful so we'd love
to see it
um
pictures are circulating
um with selling Sunset filming
um
how was filming the show without
Christine
her in a long time
um it was actually really nice it was I
mean there's always some drama you know
you put a bunch of women together and
drama just happens but it was a
different type of drama without having
her around and it was a breath of fresh
air to not have her around to be honest
and I enjoyed it a lot more so I'm glad
she's not around yeah what has been the
reaction from your cast mates they must
be so thrilled to see you as a mom so
excited I mean they were also supported
through the pregnancy and
um you know there's a lot of moms that I
work with and
um so I learned a lot from them
especially Brie who's new on this season
yes thank you and she's so she's a new
mommy and the girls are all supposed to
actually come down this week and meet
him and take me out for a little girl's
day so I'm looking forward to that I
love that and lastly can we expect a new
villain on selling sunset
you say the villain
well yeah um yeah
you know there's a lot of things I don't
see because I'm only you know working or
filming with so many girls and then
there's a lot of things going on behind
the scenes and a lot of talking you know
yeah I know some people were saying that
brie is the is the new Spicy Edition and
she might be the one to let people know
what what time it is
spicy for sure I mean she's a strong
woman I'd say she's a strong woman
um but she's not a she's not like
a nasty person and yeah her and I got
really really close and we talk every
single day and FaceTime all the time
always really bonded so
um she can't be that much of a if
she's good friends with me right because
I don't like nasty girls period